♪ ♪
>> Bret: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT USING A NEW
CYBERSECURITY TASK FORCE TO
FIGHT FOREIGN ATTEMPT THAT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
THE GROUP WILL ALSO TRY TO SLOW
DOWN THE AGGRESSIVE CYBER
ATTACKS COMING FROM IRAN.
TONIGHT CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER ON THE GROWING
THREAT AND SOME BREAKING NEWS
ABOUT WHAT ONE AMERICAN COMPANY
IS DOING.
>> FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVELY CONFIRMS
GOOGLE HAS SHUT DOWN AND IRANIAN
BACKED APP CALLED TELEGRAM BLACK
AND BANDITS DEVELOPER FROM
GOOGLE'S PLATFORMS.
AS U.S. OFFICIALS RING ALARM
BELLS ABOUT IRAN WAGING CYBER
WARFARE AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES.
>> FRANKLY, THE UNITED STATES IS
UNDER ATTACK.
>> IT IS THE LATEST MOVE OF THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT AND AMERICAN
COMPANIES ARE TAKING ON THESE
EMERGING THREAT FROM THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC.
YESTERDAY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
LAUNCHED A NEW CYBERSECURITY
TASK FORCE THAT WILL GO AFTER
FOREIGN CRIMINAL ADVERSARIES.
GOOGLE BANNED THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT SPYWARE APP AFTER THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF RESISTANCE
OF IRAN ISSUED AN ALARMING
REPORT.
IT EXPOSES HOW IRAN'S MILITARY
HAS MANIPULATIVE MOBILE APPS TO
SURVEIL THOUSANDS OF ITS OWN
CITIZENS.
THE REPORT WARNS WESTERN
COUNTRIES ARE NOW IN THE IRANIAN
REGIME'S SITES.
>> THEY HAVE A UNITS CALLED THE
INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATION AND A
SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT ALLOCATED TO
THE CYBER WARFARE.
THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT THAT
DEALS WITH THE CYBER WARFARE
AGAINST WESTERN COUNTRIES BUT
ALSO MOST RECENTLY AGAINST THEIR
OWN POPULATION.
>> THE IRANIAN REGIME HAS RUN A
VERY PUBLIC MESSAGING CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE WESTERN WORLD
TARGETING ITS MAIN ENEMY, THE
UNITED STATES.
IN DECEMBER, A MASSIVE PUBLIC
PROTEST IGNITED IN TEHRAN AND
QUICKLY SPREAD TO MANY OF IRAN'S
MAJOR CITIES.
U.S. INTEL COMMUNITY BEGAN TO
SUSPECT IRAN WAS USING SPYWARE
TO LOCATE AND THEN ARREST
PROTESTERS.
U.S. INVESTIGATORS DISCOVERED
IRAN WAS ALSO TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO SPY ON AMERICANS.
>> WHILE RUSSIA, CHINA, IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA POSE THE GREATEST
CYBER THREATS, IRAN WILL TRY TO
PENETRATE U.S. AND ALLIED
NETWORKS FOR ESPIONAGE AND LAY
THE GROUNDWORK FOR FUTURE CYBER
ATTACKS.
>> WHILE MOST AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON IRAN'S NUCLEAR
THREAT, THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN GRAPPLING WITH THE
THREAT OF CYBER WARFARE BEHIND
THE SCENES.
THIS NEW THREAT IS ANOTHER
FACTOR ON THE PRESIDENT'S MIND
AS HE DECIDES WHETHER OR NOT TO